vamos a ver si podemos calcular cuánto
es 2 y 1 4 x 3 pausa en el vídeo y vean
si pueden encontrar la respuesta muy
bien hay varias formas en las que
podemos resolver esto una de ellas es
darnos cuenta de que si multiplicamos
cualquier cosa por 3 quiere decir que
tomamos 3 de estas cosas y las sumamos
juntas así que esto es igual a 2 y 14
más 2 y 14 más 2 y 14 también podemos
ver esto como dos más un cuarto más dos
más un cuarto más dos más un cuarto aquí
lo que hice fue descomponer todos los
dos y un cuarto en dos más un cuarto
ahora lo que puedo hacer es sumar los
números enteros 2 más 2 más 2 que va a
ser igual a 6 y después sumar un cuarto
más un cuarto más un cuarto cuántos
cuartos tengo ahora tengo tres cuartos
esto es seis más tres cuartos o puedo
escribir esto como seis y tres cuartos
otra forma en la que podemos resolver
esto es reescribir dos y un cuarto como
2 igual a 8 cuartos 8 cuartos es lo
mismo que dos más un cuarto y después
multiplicar todo esto por 3 esto es
igual a 9 cuartos 8 cuartos más un
cuarto es igual a 9 cuartos por 3 y
ahora podemos decir que esto es igual a
9 cuartos más 9 cuartos más 9 cuartos
que va a ser igual a que pues esto es
igual a 99 más 9 cuartos que es igual a
27 cuartos y quizá ustedes digan oye
estos números se ven diferentes pero
pueden verificar que son iguales a
cuántos cuartos es igual 6 enteros 6
enteros es igual a 24 cuartos más tres
cuartos es exactamente igual a 27
cuartos y con esto terminamos